No Ramon! I would. Okay.
Cisco! Somebody told me you've been a very naughty boy this year.
Why don't you come over and jingle my bells, huh?
Sweet baby Jesus.
[Gipsy's teasing in the background]
Told you. Not a break up cube.
Hey everybody! Happy Holidays :) We got our flash Mid-Season Finale.
Let's break it down. There were so many comic book Easter eggs
and we're finally getting what looks like the 'Trial Of The Flash' from the comics, a bit with a little twist.
How many of you did a double-take and remember this moment from the Season 1 Finale?
With him sitting in prison.
They might actually pay this off now.
But if you are finding me for the first time, be sure to subscribe to get everything! There's gonna be a bunch of DC TV
stuff happening between now and when everything comes back. I'll explain that at the end of the video.
There is a new round of that Flash ring giveaway.
But we'll do Easter eggs as we go along because there was a lot of comic book stuff happening
amongst other pop-culture references. So number 10: The Thinker engineers a scenario whereby
he's able to yoink Barry and have Amunet Black steal Caitlyn at the same time, just to keep team Flash busy.
So it took to the end of the episode to find out why he did that exactly.
But it was all on purpose. Like he wanted to divide the
resources of team Flash so that they'd be chasing their tail long enough. So that Barry wouldn't be thinking about what Amunet Black was doing.
with the new Dominic character, who is Meta-Human Number 6. So remember: there are 12 of them total and this is only number 6.
Implying that he'll also be able to enter other Metahumans minds.
I think a lot of that just depends on how good the actors are that they bring on. Like it's a really weird
performance when you see the Dominic character go into Thinker mode, like he reveals that it's actually him inside that body
and it's not the person that Caitlin saved.
But number 9, you may have seen that deleted scene that I posted earlier. Barry and Iris come back from their honeymoon.
They drop a whole bunch of Netflix Stranger Things references. 11.
There's another Spinal Tap reference and 11 the character from Stranger Things.
But it's all just part of the Ralph Dibny arc during the episode where he's like slowly coming around and being less of a jerk.
But he's the one that sets up that Caitlin arc. Number 8: by telling her that Killer Frost is way cooler than she is. So
you know make all the Frost puns that you want.
But I'm actually kind of glad that they're not pairing them off as a
romantic couple because I feel like they've done that to Caitlin too many times.
It seems like they have a little bit of chemistry together, but she still thinks he's kind of a douchebag.
But a lot of you have been asking if there is a drink named after Cisco,
if there's like a Vibe version of the coffee?  Maybe by the end of the Season.
I don't think there is now.
They only have the Flash, Zoom, pretty much every evil speedster and now Killer Frost. So with the exception of Barry
it's almost like villains are the only ones that get coffees named after them. Like the secret Zoom version of the coffee is supposed to
be so loaded with caffeine that it's like being on crack. BUT number 7: meet Brainstorm.
So Cisco gives him his comic-book name: there have been a couple different versions of the character.
There's the pre new-52 version
and then there's the new-52 version. The funny thing about the new-52 version is that he was actually a Mister Terrific
villain. He actually showed up during his brief solo title.
The Silver Age version of the character who flies around in a chair interestingly
enough kind of like the Thinker flies around in the chair was able to use his mental abilities to turn the other members of the
Justice League into drones with the exception of Batman who was able to defeat him.
So it sounds like for the time being the Dominic character is going to be around
but as the Thinker and he'll be using his telepathic abilities to
physically control other people and get them to do what he wants. So whereas before,
he was sort of pulling the strings from behind the scenes. Now, he can do so in a more literal way.
But obviously I think there being six more
meta-humans from the bus for them to uncover. At some point he will jump into a different body.
Maybe I'll do a separate video about it later.
But it is possible because we got that scene from the Reverse Flash during the crossover where he said: "I wonder what face
I'll be wearing the next time we meet." and we now know that Devoe can jump in other people's bodies. It's always
possible that before the end of the season he could jump in to Eobard Thawne's body.
But I don't know if they'll take it that far.
But it's just something to remember, the way they bring back lines like 'This house is bitchin.'
Which they also did again at the end of this episode.
It's almost like they say that at least once per an episode this season. We'll have to see how many more times
they do that before everyone figures out that Barry wrote down all these things that are happening in the future with these symbols.
But number 6, I know you're all saying WTF is Wally? How come he isn't helping out? He was at the wedding.
He took them all to safety,
but if Joe came back then where did he go? So they name
drop Blue Valley again: that place where he originally came from the comics, the ginger version of the character where he fought the
Starfish from outer space. That was still one of the best Easter Eggs the show has dropped all season.
Joe explained that he went to Cambodia and while there isn't any big comic book Easter Egg there
he's probably just trying to help people out as Kid Flash, using his powers to try and do as much good as he can.
So it is a bit weird that he's not around.
It'll be interesting to see
what happens when he comes back?
Because it sounds like the show needs to find a more permanent place for him to go, because it does feel like he's being underutilized.
He's one of the most powerful
characters that they have and it almost feels like he's been riding the bench, so I think that will change relatively soon.
Number 5: the special Speed Force prison. Barry is able to vibrate out
faster than the human eye can see, so it seems like he's invisible briefly.
So he does become a little bit more powerful through the course of this action,
BUT the real thing here is that Devoe is trying to level him up so that he's even more powerful
when he takes over his mind eventually, which it seems like he's going to try to do.
But for a little while you do kind of wonder why he's inside there
and it seemed like he was gonna turn into a much bigger thing, like they searched Devoe's house and there was no trace of him.
But Joe and Harrison Wells didn't go anywhere into this special room here.
So there's this real question about where this space is.
I felt like it was gonna turn into a bigger thing
but we might find out about that later this season, because it does seem pretty useful.
But if he's walking around in Dominic's body, then maybe they won't go back there for a while.
Then there's the question of what's going to happen with the wife, because now we have the dead body, we have the trial so
arguably, she'll have to testify at that trial. So will she return home
and will they continue to use that lair? Number 4: the chase through the air was a lot of fun.
Barry is able to vibrate fast enough so that the Thinker's claws shock himself and the chair goes down.
But again because of the big reveal at the end of the episode: it sounds like the Thinker knew that that was going to happen
and wanted to engineer that scenario so that Barry would let his guard down and
stop searching for him. So for like a little while
he needed Barry to believe that he was dead so that he could get him to go back to his apartment.
So you just have to remember that at every step along the way through the episode 'Barry versus the Thinker' Barry was doing
what the Thinker wanted him to do. So he wanted this to all happen
just to get to this moment here, where he could put Barry in a situation where he would be sidelined.
But number 3: you have that creepy moment where Devoe's wife kisses Dominic even though
It's technically devoe, it's in a different body.
They have this weird connection, but you get this brief pause from her where she's not totally sure about it
but she gives him the ring, so she's acknowledging that this is Devoe.
But that look of hesitation is just laying the seeds for her
possibly turning against Devoe if he goes off the rails.
Like part of the idea this Season is that he might become so powerful that team Flash can't take him down by themselves.
This is where we came up with the cerebral inhibitor
to use against the Devoe.
Who?
At this point, it's just a concept.
I call this my "thinking cap". Just like their minds have gotten too small to handle at full capacity, mine's too small to deliver it.
This can change all of that
if you build it, of course.
It might wind up taking the help of Devoe's wife: the one person he trusts implicitly and the only reason why she would turn against
him is if she thought she were doing that to save him.
So he's jumping into all these different bodies and his wife (totally loves him) so she's in on the deal too.
But at a certain point he might go from crazy brilliant to just plain crazy
and that's when she tries to save him by turning to team Flash BECAUSE of the big twist during the cross-over episode where he couldn't
kill the Reverse Flash.
That's right, Barry Allen doesn't believe in killing people.
So just remember that as things get crazier and crazier
that the Flash might wind up trying to save Devoe from himself with the help of Davoe's wife.
But number 2: one of my favorite crazy moments in the episode
was when Joe seemed like he was ready to kill Devoe on the spot if he thought that Barry's life was in danger.
'There's no restraining order on earth that would keep me from you if I thought that Barry was in danger.'
So
just remember that for later this season, usually there are characters that go off the rails on team Flash and for a little while they
made you think that it was going to be the Flash because he started to go crazy.
No one believed him that Devoe was secretly the Thinker.
But now they do and he's the one at the end of the episode that did not run.
He's trying to do the smart thing by not running.
So he's just showing that there's a better way to solve certain problems.
They want you to think that Joe might be the person later this Season to go fully off the rails because he has a baby
on the way, so he's extra protective of Cecile, and he's extra protective of Barry.
But obviously the number 1 twist is the whole 'Trial of the Flash' and the Thinker overtaking Dominic's mind.
It was actually a pretty cool scene watching him put his mind into that body and it almost looked like Speed Force energy pulsing through
those cables when it was happening. The same way the Flash gives off a certain color of lightning.
A lot of you will remember that the Trial of the Flash is a classic Reverse Flash storyline where
Eobard Thwane was getting ready to kill his fiancee, Fiona Webb.
So he snaps his neck but in doing so kills the Reverse Flash.
Barry has to stand trial for it. They take him to the 31st century, it becomes this big comic book storyline.
They have to prove his innocence. So they'll have to find a way to use Ralph Dibny's
detective skills to prove that that body was planted there rather than reveal himself as the Flash.
They want to make you think he's gonna have to reveal his identity.
But the whole thing here is that Ralph Dibny is like 'I need to be a better detective.'
So that's where he comes in, that's where he can really help team Flash out.
But like I said earlier: Barry's seeing himself in prison.
I'm a hundred percent certain that that's how they're gonna pay that off, with this trial that's going on right now. Well
let me know in the comments.
What do you think of the big twist of the episode and let me know if there's any Easter Eggs you spotted that I didn't
mention.
But what'll happen is there'll be a bunch more bonus videos
happening during the off season.
There'll be some new Titans that will probably drop because they're still filming Episode One of that so those will be separate videos.
But I'll do a trailer video for Episode 10 in the morning.
We'll talk a little bit more about future storylines and Easter Eggs from the Trial of the Flash. So say
congratulations to the giveaway winner from my last video: TBNRlightning.
Please private message me so I can get your contact details. There's a new round in this video.
I'll just name the winner when I post that trailer video tomorrow.
But you can click here to watch that
deleted scene from the episode and you can click here for my new Deadpool 2 teaser trailer.
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight!